we engaged in this negotiation
on the basis of a joint political
declaration
that clearly sets out the terms
of our future partnership
yet round after round our british
counterparts
seek to distance themselves from this
common basis let me give you
four concrete examples
referring precisely to the text of the
political declaration
first the prime minister johnson agreed
in paragraph 77
that i quote given our geographical
proximity and economic interdependence
our future agreement must encompass
robust robust commitments
to prevent distortions of trade and
unfair competitive advantages
this is what together we chose to call
the level playing field in this
paragraph the prime minister boris
johnson agreed
to up all the common high standards
applicable in the union and the uk
at the end of the transition period on
these areas
stated competition social
and employment standards environment
climate change and relevant tax
matters we are today
very far from this objective
two prime minister johnson agreed in
paragraph
66 on civil
nuclear cooperation to maintain our
existing high standards of nuclear
safety we are very far
from this objective three
prime minister boyle johnson agreed in
paragraph 82
that our agreement should cover
anti-money laundering
and counter-terrorism financing
we are very far from this objective
four prime minister johnson agreed in
paragraph
118 to base
our future relationship on an
overarching institutional framework
with links between specific areas
of cooperation and we are
once again very far from this objective
in all areas the uk continues to
backtrack
on the commitments it has undertaken in
the political declaration
including on fisheries where
we committed to use our best endeavors
to conclude and ratify a new agreement
by the first of july 2020.
it seems it seems clear that we will not
reach the
target considering how the negotiations
in this area
are going for the moment
even ladies and gentlemen in the rare
areas
where we saw some movement this week
such as the european convention on human
rights
which still fall short of
what we had agreed in the political
declaration and finally
as a reminder the uk since the beginning
does not want to talk about our
cooperation
on foreign policy development and
defense
at all even though we agreed this
with barry johnson in the political
declaration
and to tell the truth on this point
defense and foreign policy
also as a former foreign affairs
minister in my own country
i still don't understand why
we cannot and we will not accept this
backtracking
on the political declaration